[Musique]
je suis fan de bande dessinée c'est pas
la bande dessinée que je suis belle plus
jamais non pas du tout je vais rater les
couteaux bâtons lagaf et les aventures
de big deal gaston lagaffe c'était assez
clivant dans la cour d'école y avait ce
qu'il fallait je ne sais pas du tout qui
d'eads et stéphane royer dupré qui était
passé
[Musique]
une délégation vouloir transporter
j'étais super jalouse mon frère la vie
dans sa chambre je voulais être en santé
dans la mienne et là pas de trace c'est
quand j'ai critiqué le président denis
chaîne de télévision auprès de sa femme
je ne savais pas qu'il était marié j'ai
envoyé un texto adressé à ma maîtresse
que j'en vivrais
moi j'aimais michel vaillant comme ses
plus jeunes parce que c'était le sport
automobile c'est blueberry je les relis
en permanence de a à z tout le temps
j'adore achille talon aussi je suis fan
de bd tintin les aventures de tintin le
cigare du gros les ombres les sept
boules de cristal ou encore on a marché
sur la lune
impériaux film tintin villepin tentant
film énorme
ce serait bien mais tu es bien dessinée
il avait l'air pas trop mal costaud je
ne suis pas dans de jolies voitures ce
que je n'ai pas atteint enfin la coupe
est en avant pour de nouvelles aventures
et pour moi il disait qu est-ce qui
disait c'est con je dirais même plus ce
site à capharnaüm
aucune idée bref c'est pas de bonne
compagnie se passe juste le bleu pas
face aux bleus j'avoue que j'ai pas là
monsieur le pognon son grognon
promouvant préfère km après le jour où
william jack hérisset philouze elle
prenait non
[Musique]
panoramic c'est bon ça